Over the last 30 years, we have seen the
value of our work diminish and the price
of real assets like land and homes
increase to the point that for most
people under the age of 40, the hope of
owning their own home has been lost. The
response of governments around the world
to the 2008 global financial crisis and
COVID was to defer the cost of these
events to the future. They did this by
printing money. In effect, selling our
futures to pay for their bad decisions.
This is corporatism, not capitalism.
Money printing didn't hurt those in
power nor those who supported them
because they had real assets, property,
shares, and businesses that rose in
price to match the inflation of money
supply. But for most of us around the
world, it sold our future for a fraction
of its value.
In response to this, a mysterious figure
known as Satoshi Nakamoto created
Bitcoin. He wanted to create a currency
that could not be printed on command,
thereby devaluing our labor, a currency
that could be traded electronically
between people without intermediation,
allowing all of us to participate fairly
in the economy. But if you tried to buy
your groceries with Bitcoin, you'd stand
at the checkout for at least 10 minutes,
probably hours, waiting for the
transaction to process, and the fee
would cost you more than the carton of
eggs and bag of apples. Bitcoin's
limitations meant that it stopped being
considered a currency in 2016 and was
instead called a store of value, but it
opened the door for someone to create a
genuine currency that nobody controlled,
but everyone could use. That someone is
us. We created the Gajum Maru blockchain
and the Gaju currency. The Gaju is real
money you can use. Whether that is to
buy a loaf of bread, pay for a haircut,
buy a t-shirt, in fact, buy or sell
anything. It is a currency for everyday
use. On Gajju market, anyone can buy and
sell any legal goods or services just
like you would on eBay, but at a
fraction of the cost. Like Bitcoin,
gajus are mined on a computer. Unlike
Bitcoin, mining gudges does not require
specialized equipment, nor huge power
supplies. During our protected rollout,
you can mine this on everyday computers
like the ones that sit in your home
doing nothing for most of the day. We
are working to get millions of people
like you to mine the gajumaru and be
rewarded with gajus that you can then
use as real money. At the end of 2026,
the gajumaru will open to public mining.
By then we will have brought together
millions of people like you to mine the
gajumaru. This will create such powerful
combined computing capacity across so
many millions of people that the
gajumaru can remain highly decentralized
enabling an economy for the people by
the people. To make all of this
possible, we offer a variety of mining
packages that combine all of the
software and services you need on our
website gajummining.com.
The software is simple to install and
there is a step-by-step guide that will
get you mining and participating quickly
and easily. You can buy those packages
now. You can start mining the gajumaru
and being rewarded in gajus now. Select
a suitable mining package from the
gajummining.com web store. Install and
activate the software on your device and
start mining today. This is an
opportunity to be part of a movement to
restore our humanity, our dignity, our
sovereignty, creating a better future
for everyone. For the first time in
thousands of years, you will directly
benefit from your work, your ideas
without being taxed by intermediaries or
needing permission to be part of the
global economy. We believe that
capitalism is I win, you win, we all
win. Not I win, you lose. That's
corporatism. We refused to pursue
venture funding that would demand we
play the corporatist game and chose
instead to grow this movement by giving
everyone the opportunity to benefit from
their contribution to the movement. Just
like being able to mine Bitcoin in 2008
or 2009, getting early access to mining
the gaju mari now allows you to mine the
greatest number of gajus and benefit
most from being part of this movement.
We want to share that with you. We want
the whole world to be part of this. We
want everyone who cares about our future
to get on board and take this from a
movement to a reality. We want to see an
economy for the people by the people.
Now, join us. Put your fingerprints on
humanity's story, our history. Be a
leader in the economic emancipation of
humanity. It's simple. Go to
gajummining.com. Select the mining
package that's right for you and get
started today.